the Joe Rogan experience for the average
person that is sitting around reading
these articles that say don't worry our
readings are there's articles that say
this is the end of humanity what what
could these people do like what what
could they do and what do they do if
they get infected well first of all
neither those kind of articles are
correct and we have to make sure that we
get that message out to people that is
Sarah we need straight talk right now
you know and and part of it is it's so
hard to you hear from people who
supposed experts what's this going to
happen or not happen you know and and
let me just give you an example because
we've heard a lot about well it's going
to go away with the the chronic of the
corona virus with the seasons okay when
it warms up it'll go away well you know
the other corona viruses that we have
that we've had to worry about with SARS
which appeared in 2003 in China and when
that came out of China in February 2003
it took us a little while to figure out
that these people really aren't that
infectious tilde five or six of their
illness and then they really crash and
burn and mininum would die but what we
did was basically by knowing that
identify these cases in their context
quickly and so if they had symptoms
brought him in put him in these
isolation rooms so they wouldn't infect
anybody else and it took until June to
bring out in her control
that had nothing do with the seasons
MERS which is another corona virus
that's in the Middle East it's in the
Arabian Peninsula the natural reservoir
for that is camels in China by the way
SARS it was palm civets and we a type of
animal food rodent that we got out of
the markets there in the Arabian
Peninsula we're not going to euthanize a
1.7 camels you know to try to get rid of
MERS and there it's a hundred and ten
degrees out and this virus is
transmitted fine thank you I mean it
goes from animals to people it goes in
the hospitals there's no evidence that
seasonal there so that's a good myth to
expose right away this is not something
that's going to cure up when it gets
warm and it you know if it does it won't
be because there's a model for it what
will it be because how does a how does
something like SARS run through a
population and then stop being around
anymore well it wouldn't have but had we
had good Public Health
we had you know the same kind of
transmission we're seeing this
coronavirus for your infectious before
you ever get sick where you're highly
infectious remember with SARS now you
didn't really get infectious tell your
Sixers you know six days of illness and
you knew that you were in trouble and
then you could isolate you and we didn't
understand that at first and we transfer
virus transmitted so that's why SARS
stop murder stops because we don't get
rid of the camels so it keeps hitting
humans day after day but then when they
go to the hospital we'd no longer allow
those individuals to transmit to others
in the hospital because we do what we
call good infection control as soon as
they get there during special rooms with
special masks and all this kind of thing
and so in that regard these corona virus
can be stopped this one's not as I said
it to be top of the program this is like
trying to stop the wind
influenza transmission you never hear
anybody saying in a bad flu the seasonal
flu year you know we're gonna stop this
one if you don't have vaccine that works
you don't it's just breathing that's all
it is
so what's the best-case scenario here
well I think as I laid out to you before
you know this could be ten times worse
than a really bad seasonal flu year and
our grandchildren well it will hit you
know primarily the older population and
those underlying health problems but as
I mentioned also you know we have a lot
of people who have other risk factors
obesity high blood pressure is another
risk factor where you can have a really
bad outcome with this and so we don't
quite know what it's going to do yet I
think you know we've been right on the
mark predicting where it's going to be
today
I think from here on out I can tell you
it's going to stay around for months
it's not going to go away tomorrow we
got to stop thinking about if we just
get through tomorrow that's it so if
we're gonna go to schools we're gonna
tell people not going to probably gonna
cancel big events how long are we
prepared to do that what are we gonna do
we have to ask ourselves that I think
the big thing is eventually enough
people get infected or it'll be like
putting reactors and the rods and you
know rods in the reaction I should say
and then that stops it by itself but
also because if you're if two of the
three of us in this room were immune
right now to it because we'd had it and
recovered and had protection because of
natural protection then I couldn't
transmit to anybody so that's what's
going to happen if you had enough people
will get infected
ultimately then it'll slow down and stop
transmission that way but that's a heck
of a price
to get there is it safe to say they were
fairly fortunate that this isn't
something like the Spanish flu or
something that's really ruthlessly
deadly well that's where I think we have
to be really careful just back up about
0.1 percent of people who get seasonal
flu diet and grants mostly older or
younger people okay that's one out of a
thousand with this one right now in
China we're seeing between two and three
percent of the people die and some say
well that's way too high it's not going
to be that high it's going to be lower
but again and they say that because we
didn't pick up all the milder illnesses
okay but on the other hand we have a lot
of additional people in countries like
ours that have even more risk factors
for having bad outcomes in China and so
Spanish flu the one you mentioned 1918
that was about a three to three point
two percent case fatality rate now it
did preferentially impact 18 to 25 year
olds say they were the hardest hit group
and why was that well you know it has to
do with your immune response again we
think that what happened is when this
virus got into you it created we call a
cytokine storm which is an antibody
response in your body that's out of
control and it basically you destroy
yourself and it sets this thing up to
trigger it off so the healthier people
had the more adverse reaction to exactly
or the other group that has had a real
challenge with that or pregnant women
and pregnant women have a very unique
issue one is of course they have some
constriction of their lungs just by the
very physical mass but also their immune
system is really at a heightened state
at that point there's a part of that
immune system and that woman says this
is not all me get rid of this it's like
a rejection of a graft and the other
part saying this is the most precious
cargo over carry you know I got to make
sure I don't lose it and when that virus
got in between those two it started
again that same kind of cytokine storm
now the thing that concerns us about
this what we saw in in in 1918 I
mentioned just three plus percent this
one could be as high as 2% so it's
somewhere between a really bad flu here
at 0.1% and it could be as high up here
you know getting closer to 1918 like and
that's the numbers I just gave you a few
minutes ago from
the American Hospital Association of you
know $480,000 in this country over the
next six to twelve months
[Applause]